[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHARLES WRIGHT: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Glad for you guys for
joining our session here
on Considerations for Migrating
Workloads to the Google Cloud.
Let me give you a little
background on myself first.
My name is Charles Wright.
I am a managing director for
Deloitte cloud engineering
team.
A little background
about myself,
I started in data center
transformation, right?
A long time ago
when data centers
were cool, about 15 years ago,
and my background predominantly
was in workload transformation
and data center.
All right, so I
spent a lot of years
sleeping on data center floors,
migrating workloads, OK?
And as anybody who
has ever worked
in that kind of business,
you spent a lot of time
away from your families, right?
A quick story about my
data center experience.
I was at a Dallas data
center doing migrations
for an enterprise client,
and I spent three days there
straight.
We didn't smell too good at
the end of the third day,
and we were literally eating
on the data center floor.
I mean, pizzas, hot dogs,
we were ordering barbecue.
It was bad.
And the data center team
came to us and said,
you can't eat on the
data center floor.
This is a violation of policy.
I said, yeah, but we've
been here three days,
and we haven't gone home.
And we haven't eaten.
We haven't done anything.
And they said, well, we're
right next door to the police
station, so if you don't
take this food out of here,
you're going to jail.
So at that point, I realized
that data center consolidation
was not more important
than going to jail.
So we took the food out and,
you know, moved forward.
But that's kind of
been my background
and what I've been doing for
the last 15 years, right?
Prior to working at
Deloitte, I had a startup
called ATADATA, which is why
I'm wearing this shirt today.
ATADATA was a software
product designed
to move enterprise
workloads to the cloud.
We were recently
acquired in January.
So this is my first speaking
engagement under the Deloitte
banner, so please be nice to me.
I'm not used to working
for a giant firm.
I'm still in
startup mode, so I'm
getting used to working
for a big company.
So part of our
go-to-market was around
building enterprise-grade
technology
to answer the challenge of
transformation to cloud, right?
You know, I'm old
and don't be fooled.
I'm very old.
That's what happens
when you get acquired.
You can get pretty, go do a
makeover, and everything else.
So I spent a lot of time solving
a lot of these challenges
for decades, right?
And anybody who's ever
done this, it's not easy.
OK, and it's not
just the technology.
People can make cool software
to answer problems and deal
with challenges.
The challenge comes
with business--
understanding the
business reason
why transformation exists--
and that's what
makes it complicated
because I can make
software that can
move thousands of workloads.
But if your business
can only take
one workload moving a month,
then that's just what happens.
So what I'm here
to talk about today
is understanding really
what the complexities are
in this type of business
and really understanding
how to get there
and how we do it.
And that's the reason
why I'm here today.
So let's talk about it.
So if you look at specifically
the cost associated
with transformation, $3,000
is usually the amount of it
takes to move one
server to the cloud.
That used to be a
lot more when you
were talking about a data
center enterprise transformation
exercise.
So the cost has gone
down, but manually, it's
still an extreme challenge.
How do you walk
into your clients
today and talk about one server
costing $3,000 from a services
perspective to
move to the cloud?
That's how many
months it'll take
after a manual process of
moving this workload into cloud.
35 months to break even.
And then, you talk
about 80% of the team
will fail to achieve what
the client is looking for.
So what does this tell you?
It costs a lot of money,
it'll take you three years
to break even, and your
customer will be unhappy
80% of the time.
Wow, let's go to
business together.
That sounds like a
winning strategy, right?
No.
So the reality is automation
solves challenges at scale.
I was preaching this eight
years as the head of my startup.
I still continue to preach it.
Automation allows you
to have repeatability.
It solves for human
error, and it can actually
save in return a significant
return on investment.
So how do we do it, right?
What are we concerned about?
What are the challenges?
So part of what our
platform did and still
continues to do as
part of Deloitte
is look at these factors
when planning and addressing
some of these challenges.
So the first thing
you want to do--
and I always tell people this.
My successes in my past life
and up until today, planning
is a significant part of
any successful engagement.
I believe 80% of your successful
engagement comes from planning.
It doesn't matter if
you have a magic tool.
Doesn't matter if you
have a genius that can
make servers work magically.
It's planning because I can
give you a great weapon,
and if I don't show
you how to use it,
you might point it at yourself.
So really, from a
strategic perspective,
the planning is critical.
And so how do we approach this?
So the first thing
that we do, and we'll
start all the way to the left--
well my left, your right--
is comprehensive
affinity reporting.
What does that mean?
Through the automation,
we're going to go ahead
and map all the
interconnectivities
from your application stack.
Now, you might say--
and you guys are technologists,
most of the people
here are technologists--
well, we have monitoring tools.
We have all kinds of stuff.
You're right.
There's a lot of tools that do
certain jobs, but what we did
was create one
tool to do one job.
So if you're trying to put a
screw into a wall-- and I'm
not very handy.
In my earlier days, I used a
hammer because I'm just lazy.
I know it's got a
little star thing in it,
but you can still hammer
that picture in, can't you?
The minute you hammer
that screw into a wall
and you hang a
picture on it, you
know it falls down because
that screw should not
have been hammered in.
But just like
anything else, we want
to use hammers to lay in screws.
So we'll get a
monitoring solution
and say, oh, that'll help
me do my infinity mapping.
The reality is is
that you really
need the right tool
for the right job.
So in this instance, we actually
designed this technology
for this specific exercise.
And the exercise was
trying to understand
how these applications
are communicating
for the specific
reason to move them.
We're not discovering it
because we think it's important,
we think it's cool,
and it's great to know.
If we're going to
move this application,
it has to be connected.
And if it's connected
to something,
that also needs to move.
That's how that was designed.
Secondly, it removes
subjective reporting.
What does that mean?
Everybody's been here,
worked for a company.
Turnover, attrition,
people leave.
Information leaves with people.
I can't trust the
third generation
guy who owns an
application he's just been
managing that he didn't build.
I'm not saying I
can't trust him,
but he probably
doesn't trust himself.
I think I know how
this thing works.
Well, you don't want
to bet your career
on what somebody thinks they
may know about somebody else's
work.
So what this does
is it eliminates
the process of guessing
or interviewing
a gentleman about a
potential application stack.
The need for a comprehensive
view of the current environment
or maintain current
state of infrastructure.
I'm sure everyone's
used a CMDB to do work.
Everyone in here, CMDB?
I go to clients all the
time, and I say, OK,
let me see your CMDB.
They usually give me
the CMDB like this.
I sent you the CMDB.
OK, that's how they do it.
That's not very
confidence building
when I have to plan a
transformation on a banking
client that can't
suffer any downtime.
That's their CMDB.
So I really don't
want to trust it.
So what I do is basically
through the collection period,
I create a up-to-date inventory
of the client's infrastructure.
That's significant.
It might sound like it's easy.
I'll give you a
real case scenario.
Went to a client, they
had 10,000 servers.
We discovered 10,000
servers, just not
the 10,000 they told us about.
That was a really funny,
interesting story.
I sat down and said, customer,
here's 7,000 of your servers.
We can't find the 3,000.
The client's like,
we have 10,000.
I said, well, we found seven.
And they said, well,
what about these?
They did the same thing.
Here's 3,000 more servers.
Can you look at those?
Next thing you know, we
reconcile their environment,
the client was happy,
now they have a plan.
But imagine if the
same client would
have went off their CMDB to
do any type of transformation
activity?
It would have been
complete disaster.
So the mapping portion
and planning portion
is significant.
Outside of clouds, servers
are underused by 43%.
We all know what
VMware used to be.
Everybody here who ever
been a VMware person?
I was certified in
VMware in my past.
What do we do?
We have templates.
We got template a,
b, c, d, e, f, g.
We would coordinate
and build environments
in a templatized way.
Well, that means we'd have these
giant servers that we're not
really using and maximizing.
Do we want to bring that
same platform to cloud?
And the reason why I'm
talking about this,
this is not a exercise
in manually building
infrastructure.
You don't want to do that.
We want to use the
Cloud Automation.
We want to use scripting.
We want to use our technology to
build out this infrastructure.
We do not want to repeat our
failure on-premise in cloud.
So by mapping it,
we're going to tell you
how your current servers
are being currently utilized
so that you can
size your servers
appropriately for future state.
That's important
because, first of all,
it cuts down costs immediately.
I'll give an example.
Anybody here who uses Microsoft
SQL licensing, for instance.
Your licensing is attached
to the size of your servers
that you're moving.
If I move a server
that I'm using 43% of
and I have multiple cores
and multiple disks and CPU,
my Microsoft licensing
costs are this high.
You can get in front
of your customer
and change not only the
way their computer is being
consumed or how much
of it, but save cost
to the customer with
their cloud adoption move.
So you can take that
same conversation
and take it from a
technology perspective, which
is the conversations
I used to have,
and move it into a business
perspective and conversations
around taking money back
into your own business.
That differentiation.
So let's look at what we
did and what we didn't.
So now we've moved
on from there.
Here's the other thing I
want to make a point about.
When we do the mapping, we
also right size the instance
because we talk
about utilization.
We also monitor performance
metrics, CPU, RAM, disks,
to determine if they
need a specialized AMI.
Should they use a
disk intensive AMI?
Should they use an AMI that
is for CPU intensitivity?
Whatever that we prescribe
the customer's getting
ready the benefits of cloud
almost immediately after they
get there.
So we're cutting costs,
we're cutting down
their compute
footprint, and then
we're also saving them
money from licensing.
But we're also saving them money
off the size of the instances
they're provisioning.
So it's a significant
differentiation.
So let's talk about migrating.
So one of the things that we
used to do-- and this was ATA.
It means any-to-any.
We're here at Google, so
we're any-to-Google today.
But part of the platform
removes the dependency
on infrastructure.
So if the client is on AWS,
they can come to Google,
from VMware to
Google, Google back.
Doesn't really matter.
We can support portability
between any of the structures,
so that's a big difference.
So there's no vendor lock.
So you're really going to get
the best value for cloud not
just from a cost perspective
but a performance perspective.
So I don't want to put you
on the Walmart of clouds.
We don't want to go
in that direction.
What we want to do is
balance capability and cost.
Those are the kind
of conversations you
can have with your customers.
Now, I've been at
Google for years.
I know what their
cloud is capable of,
but that doesn't mean
they're the market leader
from a consumption perspective.
So there's some
conversations that we
could have about how the
client can save money and take
advantage of cloud capability.
Now, manually migrating a server
is 10 times more intensive.
I've been there, I've
done manual migrations.
Those are the last
things you want
to do because of the complexity,
the chance that it could fail.
Those are things you
don't want to do.
So with automation,
it also cuts down cost
and reduces the effort.
I'll give an example.
Last month-- well, it was
about two months ago--
I was in India, and we
were doing a launch.
And we migrated 1,000 servers,
and I think the whole process--
you know, they
weren't big servers--
but it was like 18
minutes to launch.
And they all finished
within seven to eight hours.
A thousand.
That's a lot of servers.
No enterprise is
going to do that,
but we did it in our
environment just to see
what our capabilities were.
But just imagine
scale, what you can
solve when you remove barriers
such as human rest, sleep,
and food.
So there would be no eating
on data center floors
if you got automation, right?
So there you go.
OK, this is going backwards.
I just want to make sure I
haven't been talking this long.
All right, sometimes I
forget how long I talk.
So as far as management, so
one of the other things that we
talk about with cloud is every
time you have a cloud platform,
there's a cloud console.
There's a management portal.
There's a skills transfer.
There's guys who need to know--
if you have a
multi-cloud approach,
you have Google experts.
You have VM guys on-premise.
You may have another
cloud provider.
So when you have the
capability of management,
you're able to manage
across all platforms,
have one single pane of glass.
So with the product
and the capabilities
that we have at Deloitte, we're
able to provision Greenfield,
Brownfield, portable
apps, move applications.
We're building out in
our roadmap microservices
conversions from VMware.
So we can automatically
take, say, virtual machines,
convert them into market
services in different types
of containerization platforms.
So those are some of
the things that we're
thinking about for the future.
And then, of course, we have
our own mitigate platform,
which is a DR platform,
which is currently
running on a competitive
cloud, but we are bringing
that to Google in the future.
So what are Deloitte's
cloud capabilities
from a migration perspective?
We talked about
the journey, right?
The client already normally has
decided what they want to do.
They may not know
where they want to go.
So those are the kind
of conversations we want
to have with our customers.
Build what's best.
I'm a proponent on
movement and transition,
but that doesn't mean that
lift and shift is the only way
to get there.
Obviously, there's
multiple different ways.
You can re-platform.
We can rebuild applications.
You can optimize in cloud.
All of those outcomes
are possible when
you know multi-tiered approach.
And then advancement
in operations.
One of the biggest issues
I've seen in cloud--
is not cloud, is
not technology--
is people.
Where are the people to run this
and manage this environment?
I assume some of you guys
are in the audience today.
But the reality is
the biggest obstacle
I've seen to change
is the customer team.
We have the leadership
team that wants cloud,
we have the business that wants
cloud, but cloud is a new job.
Where are the skills?
Where are the people
that can manage this?
How do we transition
that conversation
to our team to educate them
on how to support, manage,
and understand the
DevOps kind of cloud
approach versus a typical
infrastructure approach?
And that's from a perspective
of advancing operations.
So when we talk about
initiating, engaging,
converge, mobilize
in an adoption scale,
that's all cloud and cloud does.
But getting there
is the challenge,
and that's what we're talking
about with our product set.
So what is a
migration lifecycle?
This is our product set
as it was designed prior
to acquisition, and
this is actually
how it lives inside our
Deloitte services team now.
Phase one, as we talked about,
is our application analysis
migration prioritization.
Migration prioritization
is significant.
I'm going to talk a little
bit about that today.
Migration prioritization
is what happens
when you plan a migration.
That means you may have
thousands of workloads.
You're not going to move
your SAP workloads on day
one of your migration plan.
That's not happening.
I know you guys want to do
that, but no, you can't do it.
So prioritization
will allow you to--
and this is through automation.
We will tell you which
workloads are easy to go first.
That's significant because
it's going to enable your team
to know, have the answer.
OK, guys, we're moving our
enterprise in 50 waves.
These are the waves,
and this is how they're
going to be broken down.
We'll actually give you
a plan on how to execute
your transformation safely.
Automated infrastructure
analysis, we talked about that.
Performance metrics.
We talked about
sizing, rightsizing.
We talked about what cloud is
best suited for your workload.
We'll even tell
you a cost analysis
on how each workload
group or cluster is best
suited price-wise
for which cloud
because, at the end of the day
when the rubber hits the road,
you have to have a conversation
of cost with your customers.
You have to understand that's
going to be a conversation.
Well, we're going to be able
to provide that for you.
Readiness planning, so we
talked about this a little bit
earlier as well.
Migration task
force setup, we're
going to put a team together.
Wave planning, we
talked about that.
Security and governance.
When you get to the cloud, you
still have security concerns.
You still have maybe even
more security concerns
than you had on-premise.
All of that is important
and part of your strategy
of planning.
So before you move, you have
to have the house set up.
You have to have the
foundation set up.
I always talk about migration
as, essentially, the movers,
but you don't consult the
movers until you have a house.
You have a foundation, you
have walls, you have plumbing,
you have electricity.
Once that's all set up,
that's your security,
that's your governance.
You have to have doors in
the front of your house
before you move
your furniture in.
So all of that is significant.
Foundational services planning.
What are you planning to do
when you get to the cloud?
What is your plan?
What is your strategy?
Is it just a lift and shift?
Infrastructure as a service?
Are you using PAS?
Are you using
database as a service?
All of those things,
all those conversations
need to have been had
and everything needed
have been set up.
Pilot landing zone build-out.
It is as describe, pilot.
You've got to prove this
concept actually is viable
before you make a wholehearted
decision to move to the cloud.
And then migration.
For instance, we talk about
the waves, the execution.
All of that is part of
our readiness planning.
Then we talk about execution.
And all of the products
I talked about here,
ATAVision, ATAMotion
handle that.
This is really the
next level, the future,
of what we feel
where cloud is going
to go from a
transformation perspective.
Part of our phase three
is OS transformation.
Part of the capabilities
in the platform
allow you to transform
workloads to different types.
For instance, you can
take a Red Hat on-premise
and convert it to
CentOS on Google.
You can take AWS Linux and
convert it into CentOS or Red
Hat running on Google.
That's significant
because see, AWS
thought they won the game when
they created Amazon Linux.
Where we cracked the code,
and we can take Amazon Linux
and convert it into
Cent and Red Hat.
That's huge because now, the
monopoly and the vendor lock
is a complete broke.
Now, I'll give you an example.
We had a customer that
was a retail customer that
wasn't happy with
their relationship
with that other provider
I just mentioned.
They needed to move to Google,
but they were running AWS Linux
Paravirtual.
Anybody know what
Paravirtual VMs are?
Oh, it's really ugly.
Google doesn't
support Paravirtual.
We converted them to
HVM on Google on CentOS.
So they took the
whole enterprise,
migrated it off,
put it on Google,
converted it from
Paravirtual to HVM VMs,
and turned them into
CentOS on Google.
It's like magic, really.
I didn't do it personally, but
I had a really smart team that
came up with this capability.
So what else are we
doing with transform?
We're taking on-premise
databases, like Oracle,
and converting them.
So Postgres and
MySQL on database
as a service platforms.
That's the next level
of transformation.
So when we talk
about lift and shift,
we're changing the vernacular.
We're not just going to
take your workload as is.
We're doing conversions
of technology now.
So if anybody snuck in here
from any competitive product,
I'm sorry you had to
hear that because that's
at least three years
for work for you guys.
You better get started.
I think you should leave
the session now, actually.
Get started immediately.
But that's where we're headed.
We're pushing the
envelope of stack.
So all of the lift and
shift is still happening,
but we're going to
change the game.
We're talking about taking
VMs, as I mentioned earlier,
containerizing them through
automation, not manual effort.
So we already have guys
working on this today,
doing live projects today where
they're going in with clients
and containerizing their
network, their infrastructure,
through automation.
Huge.
So this is where all
the fun's happening.
So when you ask me about the
transition to acquisition,
this is the fun
I'm going to have
for the next couple
of years here
at Deloitte is
moving the envelope
and challenging all the
other providers in our space
to meet that challenge.
And then finally,
Mirror cutover.
So enterprise workloads
are extremely complex.
We all know this.
SAP, extremely complex,
highly transactional.
How do we move them?
We're listed as one
of the only providers
globally that is verified
by multiple cloud providers
as a tool of technology of
choice for SAP workload.
And the reason why is this--
Mirror.
So part of our engine
constantly mirrors delta changes
to the workloads as
they're running live.
So we migrate all these
complex workloads live
and we're constantly
synchronizing them.
So when you're ready to
flip the switch, voila.
You're on the other
side of the fence.
It didn't take you a
three-hour cutover window,
and your enterprise
workloads are intact.
We moved over
2,000 SAP workloads
in the last 18 months.
So when people talk about
how hard SAP is to move,
we just do it.
It's like everyday work for us.
So we don't have a
problem because that's how
the architecture was designed.
So this looks like an
infomercial for my company,
but it's really not.
It's really Deloitte's,
just so you know.
And I keep seeing
this all over again,
but I've actually walked through
many of this stuff already.
But we talk about
projections, migrate, manage,
and then, of course, we have our
own disaster recovery product
called ATAGuard, which is
running on a competitive cloud
today, which will be
moved over to Google.
So all of these modules,
we talked about--
Discovery, Motion, Transform,
Sphere, and Guard--
they all fit under one platform.
It's called ATASphere.
So ATASphere is
the central brain
of the platform that
allows you to control
all of these manually.
He had to leave because
he had three hours--
he has three years
to catch up on.
I think I saw [INAUDIBLE].
He immediately took
a picture and left.
No, I'm just joking.
You better hurry
up, I'm just saying.
I told you guys to start.
Anybody else needs to
leave and start developing,
you better hurry
up and leave now.
You're gonna fall behind.
But anyway, so the module.
The platform sits on top
of all of these modules
and allows you complete
control over every one.
So when we talk about
a single pane of glass,
imagine one pane of glass and
you can see all your compute,
and have the ability to
move it, manage it, create,
or protect your entire compute.
I used to be a big
VMware fan, and that's
why I came up with
ATASphere because if vSphere
could have done this, they
would have been great.
Now they're on
everybody else's cloud.
What does that tell you?
See about decisions?
How you make your decisions
will depend on how you end up.
But this would have been a
significant advantage for them.
So that was my vision.
One single pane
of glass, control
of your entire infrastructure,
complete visibility,
complete control management.
That's power.
So you can create
your virtual subnets.
You can create virtual private
clouds in other environments.
You can move your
compute anywhere
you want without
bringing it down.
Future.
So what are we collecting?
This allows you to see
the entire environment,
but this is some of the
reporting we give you.
This is visualization.
These are outputs.
These are the cost comparisons.
This is all the host
data that's collected.
So it's a significant
amount of granularity.
So when I tell people,
when you look at this,
it's not just for executives.
A lot of these views are
not just executive driven.
There's not a lot of
pictures sometimes.
But when you are in
the trenches and you
are trying to make critical
decisions, you need facts
and you need detail.
I've seen other technologies
or other folks use spreadsheets
a lot manually.
Before this-- remember, I've
been in this a long time--
we used to have
spreadsheets, and we
used to talk to customers
and interview them.
And we used to
write all this down.
That was planning.
Think about how wrought
with error that is.
I can't even make
out, is that an L?
Is that a one?
Is that a O?
Is that a zero?
I don't know, right?
All of this stuff is
through automation.
So the technology is not going
to fudge that the letter.
It's not going to tell you
something that's incorrect.
That's why you can lay
your hat down on automation
many times is because
once you figure it out,
it becomes a repeatable
process you can execute.
So we went through this.
This is just more granularity
I'm giving you guys.
So 20 hours between
manual migrations, right?
We're talking about one by one.
Maybe you build a server,
you provision a server,
you install the application,
you move the data,
you watch it move.
It gets there, you validate
it, you turn up the app.
OK, we're done.
OK, next server.
Well, when you can do bunches
at a time or even dozens
at a time, it takes that
effort to three hours,
and then you just repeat it.
So the same 10 servers--
say I migrate 30 servers.
It took three hours.
That's 90 servers
in three hours.
Even though you break
it down by hours,
it's the same number of
hours it took to do manually.
You're doing 30 at a time.
That's just simple
mathematics as far
as efficiency is concerned.
Also, secure
deployment versatility.
All the transfer is encrypted.
We use 256-bit encryption
inside your environment.
So you already have a firewall,
you have protective networking
somewhat in there I'm
assuming, and then
we encrypt the data transfer.
So we just add layer
and layer of security
in these types of scenarios
And then we talked about this.
This is important.
I tell people all
the time, anybody
can migrate a web server.
That doesn't impress me.
I see it all the time.
I see demos, real cute
demos, small products
that say, look, we migrate
a server in 15 minutes.
I'm like, wow, that's
pretty impressive.
What was it running?
Bugzilla.
Y'all can all laugh at that.
That's OK.
Bugzilla, that's a
laughable comment.
But the reality is,
somebody tells you
they're migrating Oracle
rack in 15 minutes, that's
when you take them out back for
lying to you and thrash them.
You can thrash them,
you know, just saying.
But that's the reality.
The reality is the
enterprise is the challenge.
Bugzilla, not so
much a challenge.
So how easy is this to do?
Well, I designed this product
a long time ago for anyone
to use it because
my challenge was--
and just to give you
a little background--
I was working in development.
I was a storage architect.
I was a networking architect.
I was a Windows architect.
I was a Linux architect.
I was an AIX architect.
And I don't mean to brag.
That means I didn't
have any life.
That's not really something
you should be proud of.
But what it helped me realize is
that every time I got in a room
with all of these
people, everybody
thought theirs was more
important than the next guy.
And that's the reason
why I learned it
because I was into
Windows, everybody
disrespects the Windows guy.
Everybody knows, oh,
it's the Windows guy.
He needs pictures.
Then, the Linux guy.
Oh, we don't like him because
he really doesn't know Unix.
He had to learn Linux.
That's not real Unix.
So then I knew the Unix guy.
And the Unix guy was like, oh,
no, I meant the storage guy,
that guy.
He had all the power
because everything
was running on
high-performance storage,
and who cares what the
operating system was?
So I learned all of their
towers so I could sit in a room
and tell him to
shut up, and this
is how we're going to do it.
I'm going to eliminate
all your jobs.
I'm going to create an
interface so simple,
a Windows guy can do
a migration for Unix.
Oh, they didn't like that,
but when they saw it,
they couldn't say anything about
it because actually worked.
So when you talk about
what made me do it,
I got tired of the egos, and
I got tired of the arrogance.
There's a lot of
that in our field.
And you guys have been in
rooms with really smart people.
They didn't have
to be jerks too.
They were smart, they earned it.
But I got tired of that, so
I created this platform so I
could say, look how easy
it is for this Windows
guy on the help desk to
migrate an AIX [INAUDIBLE]
to the cloud.
And we actually did that.
So what did we do?
We made things simple.
We created one profile,
one visibility, one view.
We created all the API hooks
to 20 different clouds and nine
hypervisors.
20 different clouds,
nine hypervisors.
I was talking about clouds you
probably don't even care about.
CenturyLink, anybody
care about CenturyLink?
Nobody.
Poor CenturyLink, but they
used to be a big cloud.
They still are, they
still have a footprint.
But that's the reality.
Reality is we can go anywhere.
Anywhere their workload
is, that's where we are.
SoftLayer, Alibaba.
I mean, I don't want to drop
too many names at the Google
conference, but we know
there are other clouds.
Let's talk about hypervisors.
KVM, Citrix.
Let's talk about Hyper-V.
Let's talk about VMware.
VMware had a big foothold on
this business a long time ago.
It's slipping, right?
So how about an
interface that lets
you migrate between
all those platforms
through API so easy the guy
at the help desk could do it?
That's what we did.
So case study, what do we do?
We talked about the
big number, right?
The big number is easy when
you don't have limitations.
The way our product was designed
and built was peer-to-peer.
That means the workload
process transformation exists
between source and target.
So as long as the
pipe is big enough,
there is no processing power
being utilized by our product.
It's all distributed
in the architecture.
That means if I have 1,000
workloads, there's 1,000 pairs.
They're talking
amongst themselves.
They're transferring the
data amongst themselves.
They set up a client
server architecture
amongst themselves.
That's how you scale because you
don't care about dependencies
of infrastructure.
There's no worry
about, hey, do I
have to create a library
to store my images
and then deploy?
So any of our competitors
that are still
here who haven't left
to start developing--
I think we lost
three or four guys.
They had to go start.
So to the rest of you guys
who are going to fall behind
if you don't leave
right now, it's
a peer-to-peer infrastructure.
That means every
compute instance
is running their own
transformation amongst itself.
I think that's pretty cool.
I eliminated the whole problem.
One of the biggest
problems was the device
had to sit there and manage
all these migrations.
Well, if you
eliminate that and you
spread the compute through the
whole migration, guess what?
There's no bottleneck
other than bandwidth.
So once we procure
the bandwidth,
that's when you hear terms
like, "unprecedented."
That's when you hear words
like, "unprecedented,"
or, I never heard of that.
It's impossible.
Now, keep in mind
before we were acquired,
we used to do this
magic all the time.
And we would tell
people about it,
and they would say you're
lying, you're lying.
It's impossible.
So now that we're not having
to deal with that anymore,
we can do all kinds
of magical things.
So there you go.
So I don't how many
startups are in here.
I hope there's a couple of them.
It's possible to
build magical things,
and eventually, people
start to believe it.
So this is the use case.
I'm sure it's downloadable, but
this is stuff we talked about.
Dashboards, strategy,
30 million cost,
55,000 client developers on GCP.
So it's a big financial company.
You probably heard of them.
So what's happening?
So our biggest
thing is partnering
with the GCP platform with
Deloitte, with ATADATA
now to explode and to
do the unprecedented.
Anybody can do the
precedented, but can you
do the unprecedented?
That's what we're shooting for.
That's what we're
planning to do.
That's our goal, and now
that we're established,
we have the capabilities,
we have the backing,
we have the platform
to land, that's
what we're looking to do.
And obviously, the
capability is there.
Now, we have the
consultancy with Deloitte.
Obviously, Deloitte
has obviously
a significant
investment in providing
to the cloud services.
And now, they have the platform
and technology to do it.
So anyway, guys, thank you.
I'm 10 minutes early.
If you guys have any questions,
please see me afterward.
I appreciate your time today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]